ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره مراد هاشم مراد
ماذا في الاجواء المترافقه مع هذه الجلسه
وابرز المواقف التي تخللتها
نعم نايل سي جلسه مهمه لمجلس الامن الدولي
تعقد بمناسبه مرور عام على بدء الحرب في
اوكرانيا تعقد على المستوى الوزاري من بين
متحدثا اي دوله من داخل المجلس ومن خارجه
هناك 23
وزيرا
المراد من بطبيعه الحال سيما من الدول
الاتحاد الاوروبي والدول الجوار الاوكراني
والمراد هو ارسال رساله الى روسيا
واظهارها امام العالم معزوله حتى بما في
ذلك داخل المجلس اذ ان جميع الدول التي
ستتحدث او تحدث اليوم
باستثناء الصين الى حد ما هي بطبيعه الحال
في الموقف المناهض
للحرب في اوكرانيا
هذا الاجتماع مع ذلك ورغم هذه الاهميه
لكنه ليس معدا
لاعتماد قرار المجلس عاجز عن التعاطي مع
هذه الحرب مع هذه الازمه التي توصف بانها
الاخطر التي تواجهها الامم المتحده منذ
الحرب العالميه الثانيه لان الطرف الرئيسي
فيها هو عضو دائم في المجلس ولديه حق
النقض البيتو الذي استخدمه اكثر من مره
ولذلك كان قرار الجمعيه العامه يوم امس
الذي اعتمد باغلبيه ساحقه وعملت عليه
اوكرانيا والدول الغربيه منذ فتره من اجل
حشد التاييد له
لتصل الى هذه النتيجه ولكن كما هو معروف
قرارات الجمعيه غير ملزمه لكن ما سمعناه
اليوم ولا سيما من من تحدثوا من الدول
الغربيه هناك اشاره ايضا تستند الى هذا
القرار الان القرار الان من ضمنها ان اي
مبادره سلام تتعلق بالحرب في اوكرانيا
ينبغي ان تتسق مع هذا القرار الذي رغم انه
كان بمحتوى يدعو الى السلام ويحث على
المساعي السلام وبذل الجهود الدبلوماسيه
لكنه في الاساس يدعو الى روسيا الى سحب
قواتها وانهاء وانهاء الحرب وكذلك
العمليات العدائيه ما يعني انه من منطلق
هذا القرار ومنطلق الدول الغربيه
واوكرانيا اولا انسحاب روسيا ثم التفاوض
وهو ما ردت عليه روسيا قبل قليل سمعنا
يقول ان روسيا مستعده للتفاوض من اجل
تحقيق اهداف العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا وهذا هو هو هذه هي السرديه
الروسيه للسلام الذي تريده وهي انهاء ما
تعتبره المظالم في شرق
اوكرانيا التي يتعرض لها
الروس ايضا مندوب روسيا اتهم الغرب ولا
سيما الولايات المتحده بالرغبه في القضاء
على روسيا
اعتبر ان هذه ان هذه المساعي واضحه في
خطاب روسيا وان روسيا لم تعد تثق
بالولايات المتحده ولا بالدول الغربيه
وانها ستقف فقط بالافعال كانت المبادره
الصينيه ان صحت تسميتها كذلك حاضره ايضا
في الكلمات بشكل مباشر وغير مباشر
على سبيل المثال قال انه لا ينبغي لدول ان
تظهر او تدعو للسلام وهي في ذات الوقت
تدعم الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا وحربها
ايضا على ميثاق الامم المتحده